visite masqué à saint-rémy l'honorer
dans la ferme de la famille renard tout
en respectant les gestes barrière le
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume a rencontré les agriculteurs
de l'exploitation pour tirer avec eux le
bilan du confinement nous au niveau
français nous devons assumer que nous
sommes un pays en avance sur les
productions agricoles que nous avons un
savoir faire hors du commun que ça doit
le savoir faire doit être reconnue et
moi je veux assumer que ici des
personnes qui sont là puissent continuer
à vendre des produits de qualité soit
directement aux gens qui viennent soit
par diverses façons demain je crois que
le commerce alimentaire changera
favoriser des petits artisans et les
producteurs locaux se rendre directement
dans les fermes et sur les marchés les
yvelinois ont changé leur façon de
consommer pendant le confinement on
append de repenser notre façon de
consommer pendant le continent parce
qu'on n'avait plus le choix
donc on est allé à la ferme directement
pour acheter des produits parce que on
trouvait peut-être trop risqué d'aller
parfois dans des grands centres
commerciaux parce que certains étaient
fermés ou parce que les marchés
alimentaires étaient fermés on a moins
pu commander des choses sur internet
parce que certains services ne
fonctionnait plus donc on s'est adapté
pour la ferme renard le confinement a
peut impacter leur activité
les marchés ayant fermé pour la plupart
ils ont vu leur clientèle augmenter et
leur chiffre d'affaires est restée
globalement le même la désorganisation
la surcharge de travail font que la
marge on est réduite le chiffre
d'affaires s'est maintenu mais les
charges ont gonflé donc fatalement
l'année s'annonce comme étant moins
bonne que l'année précédente en terme de
résultat comptable maintenant
on peut pas dire on peut pas dire qu'on
soit gravement impacté on s'en sort très
bien
les douze salariés de l'exploitation
poursuivront leur production et espèrent
que leurs clients continueront à venir
jusqu'à leur ferme pour soutenir les
producteurs yvelinois